you're pretty much saying now unplug
Alpha is you know striving for
excellence not making a female as a
priority within their life span and
always I guess remain within a purpose
you know just give us a little more
breakdown on your definition of the
unplug Alpha there's different quadrants
to it but the unplugged Alpha is
basically the guy that that that sees
the code in The Matrix that understands
what the world's really about you know
the lies that have been shown to them
through government through uh culture
through marketing through education
through religion through all these
different aspects and sees through the
the uh basically and puts
themselves first you know makes
themselves the most important part the
most important component of everyday
decisions and life choices and how
they're going to direct their lives and
where they're going to go